France roche la carrière des des Beatles
de John Lennon et bien elle a commencé
en en 56 à Liverpool on se demande
comment d'ailleurs les les Beatles
auraient pu devenir comment un Beatles
pouvait devenir un vieux monsieur parce
qu'il avait 16 ans quand il a commencé à
jouer et il avait engagé Paul marcarnet
qui avait 13 ans mais on devrait avoir
des images sur leur carrière et sur leur
jeunesse il avait fondé le John Lennon
group où il avait engagé par la suite un
garçon qu'il avait rencontré dans
l'autobus qui trouvait
très très original très élégant qui
avait lui 17 ans et qui s'appelait
George Harrison et leur orchestre c'est
ensuite appelé the query man du nom de
l'école de John qui s'appelait query et
après Johnny et les moondogs et enfin
ils ont été baptisés les silver Beatles
ils chantaient dans des pubs et dans des
clubs d'ouvrier il n'avait pas 20 ans et
à 60 en 60 il partent pour Hambourg où
John trouve le 4e Beetle célèbre ro star
en l'enlevant à un groupe concurrent qui
s'appelait les Hurricanes on est loin de
la célébrité quand il rencontre en
Angleterre quand il rentre en Angleterre
pour faire leur premier disque my bnny
et en 61 arrive leur première chance un
disquire nommé Brian Epstein reçoit un
client qui lui demande my bnny et
brianstein répond j'en ai pas puis un
autre arrive
alors branstein se dit mais c'est très
curieux les gens demandent ce dis dont
personne ne parle il va écouter les
Beatles dans un petit
pub il leur propose d'être leur
imprésario et 3 ans après ils sont
passés de 500000 disques pour she loves
me 1 million pour i want
Stein les emmène en Amérique 6000
spectateurs tous les soirs en 64 5 mois
de suite ils seront parade et vendront
26 milliards de centimes de disques et
de produits divers badge t-shirt
perruque et cetera perruque parce que
entre tempemps ils ont fait pousser
leurs cheveux et lancer la mode comme
ils lanceront celle des uniformes de
fantaisie avec sergent Peppers lonely
heart Club Band et leurs admirateurs se
jetteront dans le Zen quand George
Harrison le mystique ira en Inde pour
suivre l'enchaignement du sriarashi nous
sommes plus connu que Jésus-Christ lance
John aux Américains toé des catholiques
qui brûl les Beatles en représaille mais
la Reine d'Angleterre les a décoré de
l'Ordre de l'Empire britannique l'ordre
de ceux qui ont bien servi la couronne
en tout cas ils rapportent des devises
pour un seul concert ils encaissent 160
millions au CH Stadium mais leur
impressario
bryanstein qui avait pris la suite de
John dans l'administration du groupe est
trouvé mort en 67 overdose dit-on les
Beatles ne joueront plus sur scène eux
qui vivaient ensemble commencent à se
séparer entre John Lennon et Paul il y a
lutte pour la direction John écrit les
textes Paul fait la musique après le
succès fou de Serge ppper Magical
Mystery Tour est un demi-échec John
divorce de Cynthia sa première femme
pour épouser une japonaise réaliste
réalisatrice de film
d'avant-garde Paul épou épouse Carole
Eastman l'héritière de l'empire Kodak
paul prend le pouvoir Yoko n'est pas
aimé du groupe et en 70 on emprend que
le groupe n'enregistrera plus John écrit
le mot de la fin over le rêve est fini
John se lance dans la politique il
invente le beding in qui consiste à
rester dans un lit pendant que les
admirateurs défilent devant le lit pour
défendre des causes pacifistes il
enregistre avec Yoko dans un groupe qui
s'appelle elephant memory il ne fait
plus la mode la Beatle Mania est
terminée quatre films et 10 disques
perpétue leurs souvenirs après s'être
séparé un moment du oko qui veut chanter
seul John la retrouve il venait
d'enregistrer son dernier disque un
Beatles ne meurt pas